[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
36 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good,
thanks, Francesc.
How you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm very happy
we're interviewing someone
from our team, kind of, again.
MARK MANDEL: Again.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: We're going to
be interviewing Carter Morgan.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, Carter
Morgan about Kubernetes 1.3.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, which is a
really, really cool release.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, there's
a lot of really new things.
Everything is better
and faster and bigger.
And he's going to be
telling us all about it.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And then at the end,
we'll have a question of the
week, which is, guess what?
MARK MANDEL: Kubernetes?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes, it
will be about Kubernetes.
So basically it is, hey, so I
have Google Container Engine
and I have IPs
that are ephemeral.
I want them to be static.
How do I do that?
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
you will learn that
at the end of the episode.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But
before that, we're
going to start with the
cool things of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we have
a lot of GA announcements.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
so nothing really new.
There are three products
that used to be beta
and now they are GA.
So you should-- if
you were not very
sure, you're kind of
hesitant about it,
now they're completely
ready for you.
So the first one is Bigtable.
And we discussed this with-- our
episode with Paul Newson also
then we had the
episode with Ian--
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --talking
about Bigtable, what it is.
And basically, it is an
incredibly fast and efficient
non-relational database.
I could put it like that.
MARK MANDEL: That works.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, so it is--
MARK MANDEL: For big data.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: For big data.
Yeah, there you go.
So it's, basically, we
have a huge amount of data
and you need to make sure
that you have really, really
fast access,
Bigtable is for you.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The
second one is Cloud CDN.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so if you want
to have edge caching for
assets that are coming out
of Compute Engine VMs--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You
said "cashing" instead
of "caseshing."
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
you actually said it
with an American accent.
MARK MANDEL: Oh,
that's really funny.
I was turning on my
American accent when I--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So if you want
cloud caching for VMs that
come out of Compute
Engine, Cloud CDN
is a great way to do it.
It's basically a
checkbox solution.
So that when you put
an HTTPS load balancer
in front of your VMs, you
can enable cloud caching
and use HTTP headers to indicate
whether [INAUDIBLE] should
be cached or not,
and you can actually
kick them out the cache, and
it's really, really powerful.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
and my favorite thing
is that it's incredibly
easy to set up.
Basically, you have an
HTTPS load balancer,
then you get there, you
click the checkbox, and--
MARK MANDEL: Boom.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
--and you're done.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
so that's really cool.
And the last one, I'm going
to let you explain it,
because I'm not a
network engineer by far.
MARK MANDEL: I am also
not a network engineer,
but Cloud Router is also
gone general availability.
Basically, that's
for if you have
both an on-prem and a Google
Cloud Platform network
and you want to route traffic
between the two of them,
Cloud Router is a way of
allowing you to do that.
It integrates with
our Cloud VPN system
and lets you route traffic
between your on-prem and cloud
infrastructure.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And as always, we'll have
a link from the show notes
to every single one of
those products in case
you're interested about
knowing more about it.
Cool.
I think it is time to go
talk with our friend Carter.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, this
should be lots of fun.
Let's do it.
This morning we are joined
by Carter Morgan, a developer
programs engineer for
Google Cloud Platform.
How are you doing today, Carter?
CARTER MORGAN: I'm doing well.
Excited to be here.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Thank you so much for
coming down today,
having a chat with
us about Kubernetes.
I'm pretty excited.
Why don't you tell
us a little bit
about what you do at
Google, and your history,
and all that sort of good stuff.
CARTER MORGAN: OK.
At Google, I'm a developer
programs engineer
on cloud platform team and
I've been focusing mostly
on Kubernetes.
I've gotten to make a
course on basically Scalable
Microservices with Kubernetes
with Kelsey Hightower.
I've given a talk at
IO on best practices
for orchestrating the cloud.
And basically,
just trying to make
it easy to get people
to use Kubernetes.
What are the pain points?
How do I make it easier?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I think it might be-- no, it
is not the first time that we
have a DPE, a
developer programs--
CARTER MORGAN: No.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --engineer.
But could you explain,
for you at least,
what is to be a
developer programs
engineer, like, one sentence?
CARTER MORGAN: Just one.
I only got one.
I got to make this count.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You
can maybe use two.
It's fine.
You can use dashes.
CARTER MORGAN: My job
is to be customer zero.
So I try things out, find
out what the pain points are,
and then make those disappear.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
One sentence.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That was good.
MARK MANDEL: That was good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That was very good.
Cool.
So one of the
reasons we have you
here is because you're awesome.
The second one is
Kubernetes 1.3.
What can you tell us about it?
It's the latest version?
CARTER MORGAN: It's
the latest version.
In Kubernetes math, 3
is twice as big as 2.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Obviously.
MARK MANDEL: So
that sounds great.
Before we get too far
into that, in case people
haven't gone to our previous
episodes on Kubernetes--
CARTER MORGAN: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: --do you want to
just give us a very high level
overview of what Kubernetes is?
How does it work?
What is it?
What problem is it
trying to solve?
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah.
Kubernetes is a container
automation framework
based on 15 years of how Google
ran containers internally.
So it's all open source
now, owned by the CNCF.
And what that means is basically
you can set a desired state,
Kubernetes pick up
on that for you,
and drive your current
state towards it.
So instead of having to, say,
manually run to a command line
and say, is my
application running,
Kubernetes will check that
for you, and if it's not,
it's smart enough to restart it.
So this frees up developers
to focus on what's
really important, applications.
And I can go more in-depth
if you want me to.
MARK MANDEL: Well, I
guess, it's interesting.
You say applications, but
you don't say containers.
Is there a reason
why you do that?
CARTER MORGAN: I think sometimes
there can be a confusion.
Sometimes you might
have multiple containers
that work well together and
that's your application.
I might have an NGINX front-end
that gives me secure routing
and that's talking to
my standard application.
In a talk I do in
the Udacity course,
we have this app that
just sends hello back.
So you can bundle up containers
to be your logical application.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So you
just mentioned CNCF.
What does that mean?
CARTER MORGAN: I always
get acronyms messed up,
but I think it's Cloud
Native Computing Foundation.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I just check
it out, and yeah, that it is.
CARTER MORGAN: Whew.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But
what does that mean?
CARTER MORGAN: So
what it is, is it's
a body that's in charge
of Prometheus now, which
is a monitoring
app, and Kubernetes,
and it's trying to just drive
it forward and adopt it and keep
it open for everyone
to contribute.
So this isn't a
Google-owned project.
Kubernetes is owned
by the CNCF, and that
lets people like Microsoft
work on it, Red Hat work on it.
And that's what makes it so
valuable to our community.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Very cool.
So let's go back
to Kubernetes 1.3.
You were saying it's twice
the power of Kubernetes 1.2.
Why do you say that?
CARTER MORGAN: Well, I said,
twice as big, twice as big.
Because now in
Kubernetes 1.3, you
can have up to 2,000
nodes, 2,000 machines
running your application
and 60,000 containers,
and that's all still
within the service of SLO,
which is a basically one-second
latency on API calls.
And so in 1.2, there was 1,000.
So 1.3 is twice as big as 2.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So if that keeps on growing,
1.4 will be 4,000 for the--
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah.
We're there I just
interviewed someone
and they said, well, we
want to see 15,000 nodes.
And I'm like, you're
not happy with 2,000?
MARK MANDEL: That could be
a lot of cores, especially
[INAUDIBLE] we can
run 32 core instances.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So on
top of being just bigger,
I'm assuming it's also better.
What are the new things?
What are you excited
about from Kubernetes 1.3?
CARTER MORGAN: Well, I get
excited about little features.
So even little command line
tools or flags are easier.
So now there's kubectl set.
So I can just go in and say,
hey, I want to change my image
and just change that
one command line,
which for running demos or
just ease of use, that's nice.
But there's really big
features that are exciting,
like cluster federation,
initialization containers, more
security features.
So I think it makes sense
to think about Kubernetes,
it says it's planet-scale,
and you can run it anywhere,
and you never outgrow it.
And now 1.3, we're actually
really meeting those claims.
With cluster
federation, you can say,
I want a cluster that's
on-prem and I want a cluster
that's on GCP, and that's fine.
It's perfectly OK.
Or if I want something
that's highly available.
Well, I want a cluster
that's in an Asian region
and I want one that's in the US.
So now all that's possible.
So the run anywhere
thing, totally you
can make that happen now.
MARK MANDEL: So let's
talk a little bit more
about cluster federation
and how that works.
Is this just some
overarching sort
of abstraction that sits
on top of Kubernetes that
makes it look the
same across the planet
if I'm going across zones?
Or what does that
really look like?
CARTER MORGAN: Well,
OK, so basically you
have to set up a control plane.
So you set up a
federated service.
And what this does is it
sets up a service for you
in all the regions
that you want.
It makes sure that
they're healthy
and that they can
route traffic to them.
It gives them DNS
entries and all that.
You can also do things like
set the context and say,
what region, what cluster
do I want to operate on?
And then you can manage
it all from one place.
So that's really nice.
So it is kind of sitting
on top of clusters before.
So now you control all
your different clusters
from one location.
MARK MANDEL: OK,
and if traffic's
coming into that
federated cluster,
I assume it's intelligently
routed to the least
latency, things like that?
CARTER MORGAN: I'm not
100% sure on that one.
I don't want to give a promise.
But yeah, so you have
the option of hitting
the federated endpoint
and round-robining traffic
throughout, or you
can actually go
to the region-specific endpoints
if your application wanted
you to do that.
That is probably the biggest
feature, I would think though,
of this release.
Because now, as
your service grows,
you can take it as something
from on-prem, and you can say,
oh, I want to try this on
an AWS, see how that works.
And you could do that.
Or if that doesn't work and
you want to switch over to GCP,
and I'm not saying AWS won't
work or anything like that,
but then you can
switch it over to GCP
and you don't have to take
everything offline right away.
You can have a gradual rollout,
still be highly available,
still make sure
everything works,
before you're on-boarding.
MARK MANDEL: That's one
of the things I really
like about Kubernetes is
kind of the customer wins.
You can run it anywhere.
So you just run around
basically looking
for the best Kubernetes
experience you can find
in the place that you need it.
And federation really
seems to sort of fall
into that as well, because that
gives you so much flexibility.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah,
it's really, really open.
If you look at other
features, the rkt container
runtime now in 1.3,
that just came out.
And so you're no longer
forced to use Docker.
Right now, rkt's the only one
we support, rkt and Docker.
If another container runtime
has features that you need
or want to rely on,
you can do that now.
So take rkt.
It allows you to
run basically images
that are more secure
with a stripped down OS.
So you have a VM-based operating
system running your containers.
You can also run on host.
MARK MANDEL: Really?
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah, so you
have host privilege containers
running.
And so if you need that kind of
flexibility and functionality,
now you have the
option with rkt.
MARK MANDEL: That's
really, really cool.
Now, I've also heard of this
thing called init containers.
This confuses me.
So can you explain it?
CARTER MORGAN:
Yeah, so basically
how initialization
containers work,
when you have basically
a pod in Kubernetes,
that's the basic application.
And a pod is one
or more containers
that know how to
play nicely together.
They share an IP stack.
They share volumes.
They can talk to each
other on local hosts.
But when they start up, they
start at the same exact time.
There is no guarantee on
pod 1 starts before pod 2.
Sometimes you need things
to happen in sequence
before your regular
application pods start.
Say, you wanted to
pull data from GitHub.
Well, you don't want to write
that into your application.
That doesn't make sense.
It doesn't fit the application.
You just expect the
data to be there
when your regular
application containers start.
So now with initialization
containers, you can do that.
What happens is you
specify N number
of initialization containers.
They're going to run in order,
the order you list them.
If any of those fail, your
pod's not going to start up.
If they all work fine, then your
pods, your normal application,
the container pod
will start as normal.
So another example why
this would be useful.
Say you have your regular
application container.
It does whatever
functionality it did before.
Maybe you want to register
that with a new service,
an external service, for
monitoring or health checking,
whatever it might be, you
can put in an initialization
container or initialization
step and have it register
your container without changing
any of your application code.
MARK MANDEL: OK, so
is that-- just so I'm
clear as well-- so
that's inside the pod?
CARTER MORGAN: It's
inside the pod manifest.
You write it in the YAML file.
So Kubernetes uses a
declarative syntax.
So you might write down what
you want, the state of it,
and then Kubernetes will
create that state for you.
So in that manifest
file, you're right,
there's a new initialization
container section,
and you write just the
pod, the templates.
MARK MANDEL: OK, so you
have a lot more control
now in regards to the order in
which these containers come up
in, like, one versus
another, whereas before, I
think-- I know I've done stuff
where I just run retries.
Like, oh, yeah, first time
it fails, back off, back
off again, back off again.
Now you can just be
more explicit about it.
CARTER MORGAN: Right.
And, well, in talking to
people, a lot of people
say they want to do, basically,
like, serial processing.
So maybe they have some
kind of pipeline going.
They have an application
that they want running,
but they need steps one and
two of the pipeline to run.
Well, now you can do that
with init containers.
I think that's my favorite
feature from Kubernetes 1.3.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I
was checking on GitHub
and I saw that the issue
called init containers.
It is labeled stateful apps.
What are those?
What is a stateful app
in the Kubernetes world?
CARTER MORGAN: OK, well, a lot
of times you have applications,
like web servers, you can just
replicate as many as you want.
They don't really matter.
And you hear people talk
about pet versus cattle.
So if you have a pet,
you care about it.
If it gets sick,
you want to fix it.
You want to help it.
You give it a name.
Cattle you're making
hamburgers, man.
It doesn't really
matter what's up there.
So in Kubernetes, what
we have now are Pet Sets.
And basically what this is,
is a Pet Set manages pets.
And pets have a unique
name, a DNS record,
and they are associated
with some kind of data.
So if they go down, we
want that to come back up.
We care about it.
We care about the order they
start and the order they stop.
So that's what stateful
data means in Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I
can imagine something
like that being
very useful to run
databases and things like that,
like in SQL with replicas or--
CARTER MORGAN: Exactly.
So yeah, there's two types of
databases that you you're going
to see commonly with this.
There's the quorum type,
like your [INAUDIBLE] kind
of things, where you
have-- basically you
need consensus
between multiple--
I can't even think
the word right now.
MARK MANDEL: Multiple nodes?
CARTER MORGAN:
Multiple nodes, yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Sounds like Kubernetes.
CARTER MORGAN: Right.
And then you also have
something like a MySQL database,
where you might need
to attach one NFS disk,
and you always want to
be attached to that disk,
or you always need at
least one pod or node
attached to that disk.
So these are where stateful
applications come into play.
MARK MANDEL: Does
this also account
for where you'll always
want something to come up
in a particular DNS entry?
Like, this thing has to
always be at this record.
CARTER MORGAN: Right.
So you're always going
to have the same name,
because you always want to be
able to access it the same.
So yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So you could put, like, memcache
there or other things like that
as well, where
you're like, I always
want to be able to
find this in one spot.
CARTER MORGAN: Mm-hmm.
And so one of the
complaints I've
heard about Pet Sets-- I've seen
some really cool demos with it.
I just saw a 1,000-node
Cassandra demo.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
CARTER MORGAN: Very cool.
But one of the
complaints is people
said, well, we could
do almost all of this
before with the API in 1.2.
So we've added another object.
Is it necessary?
So it seems like it
makes it a lot easier,
but there's been a
little contention on,
is this the right way?
Is this finished yet?
MARK MANDEL: Well, Pet
Sets is still fairly new.
So I guess there are some--
like, their alpha, if you play
with them, things may-- not
necessarily things may break,
but things may change
as we go along.
So there's probably
some wiggle room
there to find the
best case scenarios
for those sort of things.
CARTER MORGAN: Right.
And I'm just excited,
because in 1.2, I
was writing a flashcard
app, and whenever
I had a pod that
would die or restart,
I had to go manually
detach the disk.
So that's fixed now.
It automatically-- they
have detached controllers
that automatically
unattach your disk
and later reattach when
the pod starts up again.
So that's aside from Pet Sets.
So just stateful applications
in Kubernetes 1.3 are better.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
And I guess that also ties
back to init containers.
You were talking about
with stateful apps,
having things come up in
the right order really
is important.
CARTER MORGAN: Mm-hmm.
Yeah, so there's a lot
of support around that.
And Pet Sets, it's
a nice feature,
and I'm sure we're going to
see a lot more in the coming
months of people using it
and testing it out, seeing
what the limits are.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we've covered a little
bit about all the things
that you can do,
like more nodes,
and you can also have init
containers and stateful apps,
and you can run rkt instead of
Docker, and all those things.
Those are amazing.
There's one more thing that I
saw that Kelsey Hightower had
written.
It's "Kubernetes the Hard Way."
Can you tell us a
little bit about that?
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah.
One, Kelsey's great.
Like, great.
He's so good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We agree.
MARK MANDEL: We agree.
CARTER MORGAN: Well,
he's just really
good at getting in the
community and listening
to what their needs are.
And with Kubernetes, what
we're seeing is a lot of people
think it's really hard to
get started with Kubernetes.
Maybe the documentation isn't
quite there around the steps
to start up a cluster
or maybe there's
a lot of-- there are a lot of
steps to starting a cluster.
So what "Kubernetes the
Hard Way" is is Kelsey
just wanted to go and
document and say, OK, here
is the steps for a basic
sane default configuration
for starting up a cluster.
That's it.
That's all it is.
So now you can go and learn
everything that's involved.
MARK MANDEL: I guess
sort of the pain point
before was-- I mean,
GKE is easy, right?
You push a button and
you get a cluster.
There are cube up scripts
to firing up a cluster,
but I guess that's kind of
a "magic-y," quote, unquote.
CARTER MORGAN: Right.
It abstracts away the details.
So you don't know what's
going on in your system.
So how do you adopt
a new framework
if you don't know even how it
starts up, or how it stops,
or what are the pieces
that interoperate?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so I guess
looking through Kelsey's stuff,
he actually takes you
through step by step
and shows you everything
that you need to do?
CARTER MORGAN: Mm-hmm.
It's not everything.
There's still a little bit more.
But this is a great
starting point.
So now you see the community,
there's a SIG on it
now, a special interest group.
Joe Beda and a bunch of other
really, really smart people
are working on, OK, how do we
minimize the amount of steps
without locking people in and
keeping Kubernetes as open
as it is.
MARK MANDEL: That's
fantastic, actually.
I didn't realize that SIG
existed or it just got created.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah,
it just got started up
within the last month, I think.
MARK MANDEL: No, that's great.
That has been a common
sort of complaint point
around Kubernetes.
How do I set up clusters?
Why is this so hard?
How does this stuff work?
And so it's really nice
to see the reaction
from the Kubernetes
community and the authors
and the people who work on it.
Like, coming, OK, yeah, that's
a problem, let's fix it.
CARTER MORGAN: Right.
Yeah, it's fun, because
Kubernetes is mostly
or largely community-driven.
When you look at the
number of commits
from external people
outside of Google, outside
of the big companies,
it's exciting.
And when you see the
amount of interest on Slack
in the SIGS on the
Git issues, it's
one of the reasons
why I'm really
excited about Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So these make me think about--
not that long ago, actually, it
might have been
almost a year already,
one of our coworkers, Ray Tsang,
created a-- what was the name?
It was like a mini
cluster, Kubernetes.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, he
called it a mini cluster.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: A
mini cluster, which,
I don't know if you've seen
it, it's like five Raspberry
Pis, one on top of each other.
So do you think that the
pain he had to go through
to make Kubernetes run on that
little Raspberry Pi cluster
could be less now?
Or how hard or how easy it
is to get Kubernetes cluster
started outside of GKE?
CARTER MORGAN: Well,
there's a joke going around,
for all the people
with their Pi demos,
that they're also
running Kubernetes 1.1,
because it's too hard to--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, OK.
CARTER MORGAN: But no, the steps
are now going to document it.
One of the things,
"Kubernetes the Hard Way"
by Kelsey Hightower,
that documents the steps.
As this SIG develops
and pushes--
they're trying to have
a short timetable on it.
As they develop closer and
more, it's going to get easier.
So I think just
having documentation
was the first step.
And that's an area where
we can definitely improve,
documentation around
Kubernetes in general.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So something I've
seen in many demos that
get people quite impressed
is when you update from one
image to something else.
Migrations c in Kubernetes
are very, very nice.
Is there anything new on that?
CARTER MORGAN: Oh, yeah,
there's a new command.
I think it's kubectl rollout
status now, so you can actually
see what's going on.
If you've looked at
any of my old demos,
I used to run some
kind of script
and I would manually do this.
Well, now it's just built
right into the tool,
so you can see step by
step what's going on.
How's your cluster scaling up?
How's it scaling down?
So that's a really nice feature.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, that's cool.
So if I'm changing
from one image
to another inside Kubernetes, I
can actually see, very easily,
what's changing.
Yeah, I've done the same thing.
I've done watch commands
that change every two seconds
and done get pods just to
see which ones are up or not.
That's super, super handy.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah, there's a
lot of, again, little features
and little commands throughout.
There's a new secret.
So basically secrets
are sensitive data
that you don't want to store
in your pod or in your image.
Well, now there's a new one
for generating TLS certs.
So if you want to test
something locally,
you can just use
kubectl [INAUDIBLE]
to create some test certs.
And again, it's that ease
of use that's going to make
Kubernetes the
platform to adopt.
MARK MANDEL: I'm going
to take the opportunity
to ask a Kubernetes question
since we have you here.
And I'm sure-- this
has been covered a bit,
but it comes up a lot.
So when do I use secrets and
when do I use config maps?
CARTER MORGAN: OK.
Config maps are for string
data and they're basically,
like, so if I had NGINX
config, something that anyone
could see.
It's not a big
problem, but it might
vary between two different
runs in my container or two
different environments,
whether it's production and dev
or whatever.
Secrets are your password,
your search history,
things that you don't
want to hand out.
So you're obviously
going to want
to use secrets for information
that you want to keep secret.
MARK MANDEL: OK, so if I've
got my database records,
like, where's my database,
what's its username, what's
its password, that's a secret.
I want to put that in there.
CARTER MORGAN:
Definitely the password.
I'd probably use the
username, stuff like that too,
or an environment variable.
But definitely the
password, you're
going to want a secret for that.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
And then so, yeah, something
like an NGINX config
or something like
an Apache config,
like, whatever, who cares.
CARTER MORGAN: Now, another
thing that's really cool
is config maps, you can
notify pods downstream
when configs change.
So if I change my NGINX config,
I can notify a pod downstream.
I don't think you can
do that with secrets.
MARK MANDEL: I don't
believe you can.
CARTER MORGAN: Right.
MARK MANDEL: How does
that notification happen?
Is that, like, files change
or environment variables just
change or--
CARTER MORGAN: Environment
variables in [INAUDIBLE]
is my understanding, and there's
a downstream API for that.
MARK MANDEL: OK, cool.
CARTER MORGAN: But yeah, so
what else, is secrets can also--
and configs-- can all be passed
through environment variables.
Configs can also be passed
command line, I'm sure.
And so you have a lot of
flexibility when using them.
So I try and tell
people to use them
as much as possible, you know?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I was chatting
with someone about keeping
their WordPress config
and whether they should put that
in a secret or a config map.
And I think we ended up
deciding to put it in a secret,
because it not only contains
just basic information
about WordPress,
but also username
and passwords for the
database, things like that.
And that's actually
the wp-config.php file,
the whole thing.
But that was really cool.
I actually hadn't
thought of doing
stuff like that to, really,
just even just configure just
generally, like, a WordPress
install or something like that.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah.
Now, what I want
to learn next is
I learn how to use Kubernetes
in production more.
So someone actually
has to take the secret
and give it to the API server.
So do you use something
like Vault for that?
Where do you store
that secret initially?
That's what I want to know.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
There's a few different
interesting tools
that could help you do that.
I used to do a bunch
of stuff in Ansible
and had inbuilt encryptions.
So you could do Ansible Vault,
like you were talking about.
Yeah, that's a good question.
Excellent.
All right, well,
we're starting to sort
of head towards the
end of our time here.
Is there anything else you
want to mention or touch
on or just plug in general?
Maybe if you're going to be
somewhere or do something.
Have you got anything there?
CARTER MORGAN: Nope.
I've got an article coming
out on the Kubernetes
blog in the next few days,
and on the open source blog,
where we interview Joseph
Jacks from Kismatic and Brenda.
He's someone that's really
active in the community.
So it's cool to see him
say why he chose to bet
his business on Kubernetes.
Where he wants Kubernetes to
go in the next few months.
He's the guy that
said 15,000 nodes.
Makes me think he's
a crazy person.
And what he thinks is
wrong with Kubernetes,
what could be better.
So it's a fun interview.
So check it out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
Well, we're not going to
say goodbye or thank you,
because we're going to
continue interviewing you
for next episode.
MARK MANDEL: Yes,
next week we're
going to have a chat about
what came in 1.3 specifically
for GKE.
So stay tuned until next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thanks
again to Carter Morgan
to spend this first
episode with us, telling us
all about Kubernetes 1.3.
We're looking
forward to having him
back next week
for more about it,
specifically about
Google Container Engine.
But before we finish
with the episode,
we had this question
of the week, which
is, OK, so with
Kubernetes, it's really
easy to expose a service.
And when you expose a
service, basically you're
creating a load balancer
and you get an IP.
Now, you expose that and
people start using that IP.
And then you change
something, you
want to migrate to
the new version,
and you need to recreate
the load balancer.
How do you make it so you
will keep the same IP?
Because that IP is
ephemeral, right?
I don't want to
change the IP and make
every single one of my
customers, which is, like, two.
Yeah, I don't have
a startup yet.
But how do I keep
them from having
to follow with my IPs changing?
Just, I want that
IP to be ephemeral.
CARTER MORGAN:
Yeah, we don't want
that DNS to be
changing DNS addresses
and waiting for propagation.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Not
a very good idea.
CARTER MORGAN: That's no fun.
So it's actually
really straightforward.
We were looking at
a blog post that one
of our teammates, Terry
Ryan, wrote about this
and it's really quite cool.
So you're able to--
say, yep, you've
created that load balancer
and you've got an IP address.
You're able to go into
your console networking,
look at your
external IP address,
and it's pretty much there's
a little drop-down that you
can change from
ephemeral to static
and that makes your IP address
static, which is great.
That makes it belong
to your project.
That means you have
it and you own it.
It's yours.
What's cool from
that point is OK.
But what happens if I
delete my load balancer?
I want to make sure
I keep that static IP
address for this load balancer
for this Kubernetes service.
So there's a setting inside
the YAML that you can set.
It's load balancer IP.
It's pretty much exactly what
you would expect it to be.
And you can put
in the IP address
that you want it to have.
And if you own that IP address,
it will give it to you.
From there, you can just
kubectl apply the service
and that gives you
the IP address.
From that point forward, if you
want to just delete the service
and then recreate it or maybe
give it to another service,
you can do that.
It's pretty straightforward.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
Sounds like the obvious
solution just working,
which is always nice.
CARTER MORGAN: Which
is really nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very intuitive.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
Well, thank you for joining
me once again, Francesc,
for a wonderful episode.
You up to anything
particularly interesting
in the next few
weeks or are you just
kind of doing some
online content
and doing some other cool stuff?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
doing some online content,
working on some new
videos that I've been
thinking about for a while.
And now that I'm not traveling,
I will be working on that.
So looking forward to releasing
videos on [INAUDIBLE].
What about you?
MARK MANDEL: So when this
comes out, I will be in Israel.
After that, I'm taking a short
vacation off to Australia,
but then I'll be at PAX
Dev later in the month.
So if you're going to be
there, please do say hello.
I'd love to say hi.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: San
Francisco to Israel.
Yeah, Australia's on the way.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, sure.
Yeah, let's go with that.
Let's go with that.
It's fine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Well, have safe trips, and
talk to you all next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]